First of all there is no typical workday.
My research focus is on how bacteria resist antibiotics,
so I've been studying various issues of antibiotic resistance since my graduate student days.
So when I came here in 1982, I was studying both Staph aureus and Neisseria gonorrhoeae
and now my lab concentrates solely on Neisseria gonorrhoeae.
I came to the VA here in December of 1986.
I have a variety of administrative
responsibilities both at Emory and at the VA so I go back and forth.
Our real concern is without new antibiotics coming out of the pharmaceutical pipeline
that has very severely thinned over the years,
is that there could be cases of untreatable infection.
I think science can cure this issue, but it's going to take a lot of money,
It’s going to take political will. It's also going to take education .
I'm the product of a military family. My mother and father met in England in late 1943.
My mother was a nurse and my father was in the medical service corps.
Both were young lieutenants. She was from Providence, Rhode Island, and he was from Ft. Scott, Kansas.
I was born in Yokohama, that's where my father was stationed.
He remained stationed in Japan ’till 1956. So I was born on July 4, 1954.
You know as a kid I asked a lot of questions and people didn't ignore those questions,
so, you know, in thinking back, I had a lot of people who influenced me.
And then I went off to college in 1972 and I started graduate school in 1975 and finished my PhD in 1979.
I went to North Carolina for my postdoc from ’79 to ’82.
She was a post-op nurse on the orthopedic surgery floor at Duke University.
I have two boys and I have four grandchildren.
You know I get a lot of joy in teaching in the classroom. I give this lecture every year to undergraduates at Emory College
in Dr. Michelle Lampl’s predictive health course, on the post-antibiotic era.
I also run a graduate training program called Antimicrobial Resistance and Therapeutic Discovery Training Program.
So I'm interacting with students all the time. I love what I'm doing.
I love being a faculty member, a researcher, and that's an incredible feeling that you have.
So I wouldn't trade this for anything. I hope I have shown people some new  possibilities, some new strategies.
I've been fortunate to be funded for some time, and I hope that we can continue for some time,
because I feel like I still have contributions to make.